[Music]
transnational organized crime
representative cute threat to the United
States and to our neighbors in the
Western Hemisphere in Mexico for example
drug cartels and taking advantage of
globalization in order to move their
product across borders in to launder the
assets through our own financial system
they represent a serious threat to the
communities of Mexico to our border and
to frankly our international financial
system as a narco-state in Venezuela
that's gradually destroyed the
institutions in that country and
represents a threat to Venezuela's
neighbors and a conduit for drug
trafficking to the United States in
Colombia we have narco guerrillas that
operate with virtual impunity over
decades and now threaten the ability of
people there in Colombia to make peace
the United States can be a partner with
all of our neighbors to tackle this
problem view some asymmetrical tools to
freeze their assets but also build up
the capacity of these countries to
confront this problem in their own
national territory how do you think the
United States should work with its
neighbors to confront transnational
organized crime let us know in your
comments and let us know what other
topics you'd like a EEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds